foreign
hi I'm Yuna and I'm here to talk to you
about what's new in web UI the past few
months have ushered in a golden era for
web UI new platform capabilities have
landed with tight cross browser adoption
that support more web capabilities and
customization features than ever and as
a web developer who's wanted a lot of
these features for years I'm very
excited about where the platform is
going and really happy to be here today
to shine a light on all of the hard work
that the chromium team has been up to so
join me in this under 20 minute Journey
as we take a look at some of the most
exciting and impactful features that
landed recently or are coming soon and
it is a lot of topics to cover in such a
short amount of time so look out for the
QR codes on the top right corners of the
screen to get more information code
samples and demos to play with
let's get started with some new
responsive UI capabilities with these
new responsive features users can create
truly Dynamic interfaces that take
responsive design to the next level new
platform features let you build logical
interfaces with components that own
their responsive styling information
leverage system capabilities to deliver
more native feeling interfaces and let
the user become a part of the design
process for more personalization
container queries recently became stable
across all modern browsers and allowed
for you to query a parent element's size
and style values to determine the Styles
which should be applied to any of its
children unlike media queries which can
only access and leverage the information
from the viewport and thus really only
work on a page layout macro view
container queries are a more fine-tuned
tool that support any number of style
optimizations and layouts within layouts
in this inbox example the primary inbox
and favorite sidebar are both containers
the emails within them adjust their grid
layout and show or hide the email
timestamp based on available space this
is the exact same component within the
page just appearing in different views
and because we have a container query
their styles are dynamic as we readjust
the page size and the macro layout
shifts they look to their individually
allocated space to make styling
decisions the sidebar becomes a top bar
with more space and we see the internal
layout shift to adjust
the container query specification
doesn't stop at sizing though it also
includes the ability to query a parent
container's style values this spec is
currently partially implemented in
Chrome 111 where you can use CSS custom
properties to apply container Styles in
this example we're using weather
characteristics stored in custom
property values such as rain sunny and
cloudy to style the card's background
and indicator icon but this is just the
beginning with style queries in the
future we'll have Boolean queries to
determine if a custom property value
exists to reduce code repetition and
currently in discussion are range
queries to apply Styles based on a range
of values this would make it possible to
apply The Stylist shown here using a
percent value for the chance of rain or
cloud cover pretty powerful
speaking of powerful Dynamic features
the has selector is one of the most
powerful new CSS capabilities Landing in
modern browsers with has you can apply
styles by checking to see if a parent
element contains the presence of
specific children or if those children
are in a specific State this means we
essentially now have a parent selector
in this element we're giving an item
that has a star element a gray
background and an item that has a check
box in the checked States a blue
background all using has but this API
isn't limited to parent selection you
can also style any children within the
parent as well for example you can make
the title element bold in those items
that have the star element presence or
apply some styling to a pseudo element
using the half selector gives you access
to parent elements child elements and
even sibling elements using existing
combinators making this a really
flexible API
one of my favorite examples of logical
CSS using has is for creating quantity
queries something that we had to hack
around in the past in this example we're
leveraging the nth child pseudo elements
and looking to see if the inbox has n
plus 11 children if this is true and
there are 11 items within the inbox we
can style the pagination bar to appear
going from display none to giving it a
display value you can use this for form
error messages via invalid States
changing the layout based on the number
of items in a list and many more
examples to limit rendering performance
slowdowns for the hash selector we
recommend that you Scope it as tightly
as possible for example try to scope has
to a containing element such as a card
or nav bar rather than something more
Global like the HTML route particularly
on pages with large Dom trees building
on nth child we now also have more
advanced nth child selection on the web
the advanced and child syntax gives a
new keyword of which lets you use the
existing micro syntax of a n plus b with
a more specific subset within which to
search for example if you use the
regular nth child syntax such as nth
Child 2 on the special class the browser
will select the element that has the
class special applied to it and also is
the second child this is in contrast to
nth child two of special which will
first pre-filter all these special
elements and then pick the second one
from that list
selectors and style queries aren't the
only places that we can embed logic
within our Styles Topography is another
one now in Chrome Canary you can try out
text wrap balancing for headings using
the text wrap property with the value
balance this enables more even headings
and removes Singleton lines of text
here's what the web.dev site looks like
after text drop balance the headings and
subheadings are more uniform in length
text wrap balance uses knuff's text
algorithm to identify the most visually
balanced position for the text in a
headline while this is a great
Progressive enhancement that you can try
out today it's important to note that
this API only works up to four lines of
text so it's great for titles and
headlines but likely not what you're
looking for with longer pieces of
content
another nice Improvement to web
typography is initial letter this CSS
property gives you better control for
inset drop cap styling you use initial
letter on the first letter pseudoelement
to specify one the size of the letter
based on how many lines it occupies and
two letters block offset or sync for
where the letter will sit screens and
devices have also evolved over time and
so the web must keep up
one common problem web developers face
today is accurate and consistent full of
viewport sizing especially on mobile
devices we want 100 VH or 100 of the V
Port height to mean be as tall as the
viewport but the VH unit doesn't account
for things like the header bars and
browser Chrome on mobile so sometimes it
ends up being too long and causes scroll
to resolve this issue we now have new
unit values on the web platform
including small viewport height and
width which represents the smallest
active viewport size large viewport
height and width which represents the
largest size and dynamic viewport height
and width Dynamic viewport units change
in value when the additional browser
Chrome like the header or footer bar are
visible and when they're not
another new key addition to the web
platform are wide gamut color spaces
before wide gamut color spaces became
available on the web you could take a
photograph with really Vivid colors and
you could use it on the web but you
couldn't get a button or a text color or
background to match some of those Vivid
values but now we have a range of new
color spaces on the platform including
Rec 2020 P3 XYZ lab OK lab lch and oklch
and you can immediately see in devtools
how the color range has expanded with
that white lined lineating where the
srgb range ends and where the wider
gamut color range begins and to top off
the expanded color spaces we now also
have a new platform feature called color
mix color mix supports the mixing of two
color values to create new values based
on the channels of the colors getting
mixed the color space in which you mix
affects the results working in a more
perceptual color space like oklch will
run through a different color range than
something like srgb
and a big win for color mix solves a
long request capability the ability to
preserve opaque color values while
adding some transparency to them now you
can use your brand color variables while
creating variations of those colors at
different opacities the way to do this
is to mix the color with transparent
when you mix your brand color blue with
10 transparent you get a 90 opaque brand
color you can see how this enables you
to quickly build color systems and you
can see this in action in Chrome Dev
tools today with a really nice little
preview Venn diagram icon
and all of these features support your
ability to more easily create custom
themes and tailor your web experience to
your users with key moments of delight
to learn more about these moments and
how to really leverage new web
capabilities to create personalized UI
experiences check out Adam argyle's talk
on the subject
building new capabilities that have
clear user wins is one part of the
equation but we're also Landing
developer facing behind the scenes
features for more reliable organized CSS
architecture these include native CSS
nesting Cascade layers scope Styles
trigonometric functions and individual
transform properties
nesting allows developers to write in a
more succinct grouped format that
reduces redundancy instead of writing
card Styles card hover and its Styles
card qualifier values and their Styles
inside of a media query that might be in
a totally separate part of your code
base you can now keep them all organized
together and get the same results as
this
this capability which is something that
folks love from SAS has been one of the
top CSS developer requests for years and
has now finally landed in the web
platform
another developer pain point that we've
identified is ensuring consistency in
which Styles win over others and one
part of resolving this is having better
control over the CSS Cascade enter
Cascade layers Cascade layers give users
control over which layers have a higher
precedence than others meaning more
fine-tuned control of when your styles
are applied I recently relied on Cascade
layers for a website that I was building
which was built on a framework that used
a bundler that changed the source order
of the CSS Imports causing unexpected
styles to be applied Cascade layers
saved the day and let me clearly set up
the source order I wanted regardless of
where the style is loaded in
and the final game changing
architectural update that will be coming
to browsers soon is CSS scope styles
using at scope scope allows developers
to specify the boundaries for which
their specific Styles apply essentially
creating native name spacing in CSS
before developers relied on third-party
scripting to rename classes or specific
naming conventions to prevent style
Collision but soon you can use that
scope here we're scoping a title element
to a card this would prevent that title
element from conflicting with any other
element on the page that has a class of
title like a blog post title or some
other heading you can also use scope for
theme Styles and create pass-through
donut scope Styles making this even more
useful
another piece of new CSS Plumbing are
trigonometric functions being added to
the existing CSS math functions these
functions are now stable in all modern
browsers and enable you to create more
organic layouts on the web platform one
example is this radial menu layout which
is now possible to design and animate
using sine and cosine functions
and finally developer ergonomics
continue to improve with individual
transform functions since the last time
that we had i o individual transforms
went stable across all modern browsers
in the past you would rely on the
transform function to apply sub
functions to scale rotate and translate
a UI element this is cumbersome and
duplicitous and especially frustrating
when you wanted to apply multiple
transforms at different times in the
animation now you can have all of this
detail in your CSS animation by
separating the types of transforms and
applying them individually the
translation and rotation can happen
simultaneously at different rates of
change in different times during the
animation super handy
a huge frustration developers have with
the web platform which I also feel in my
bones is why are form controls still so
hard to style and to make sure that
we're resolving that through the web
platform we're working with the open UI
community group and have identified
three solutions to start with the first
is native pop-up functionality with
built-in event handlers and declarative
Dom structure and accessible defaults
the second is a CSS API to tether two
elements to each other and enable native
anchor positioning and the third is a
stylable drop down menu component for
when you want to customize content
inside of a select the popover attribute
gives elements some built-in browser
support magic like top layer support so
you don't have to mess with the z-index
anymore when you open a popover or a
dialogue you're promoting that element
to a special layer on top of the page
you also get light dismissed behavior
for free so when you click outside of an
element the popover dismisses removing
it from the accessibility tree and
managing Focus there is also some nice
default accessibility for the connective
tissue of the popover's Target and the
popover itself and all this means less
JavaScript has to be written to create
all of this functionality and track all
of these states
the Dom structure for popover can be
written as clearly as giving your
popover element an ID and the popover
attribute then you sync that ID to the
element which would open the popover
such as a button with the popover Target
attribute now we have a fully functional
popover
popovers are also really common in
elements like dialogues and tooltips
which also need to be anchored to
specific elements in most cases take
this event example when you click on a
calendar event a dialog appears near the
calendar item that you've clicked on the
calendar item is the anchor and the
popover is the dialog which shows the
event details we can create a centered
tool tip by leveraging the anchor
function and using the width from the
anchor to position the tooltip at 50 of
the Anchor's X position then we use
existing positioning values to apply the
rest of the placement Styles but what
happens if our popover doesn't fit in
the viewport based on the way that we've
positioned it to solve for this the
anchor positioning API includes fallback
positions that you can customize
yourself here we're creating a fallback
position called flip we want to let the
browser first try positioning the
tooltip at the top and if that doesn't
fit in the viewport the browser would
then position it underneath the
anchoring element on the bottom you can
get really granular here which may get
verbose but it's also an opportunity for
libraries and Design Systems to write
the positioning Logic for you to reuse
everywhere
finally with both of these behaviors pop
over and anchor positioning we can build
fully customizable select menus the open
UI community group has been exploring
the core architecture of these menus and
identifying ways to allow for the
customization of arbitrary content
within them take these examples the one
on the left has a color bar
corresponding to calendar event colors
the center select menu shows different
typography preview Styles and on the
right we have a country select showing
flags for Clear visibility
in the first select menu here we have
these little color dots corresponding to
the event types as they would appear on
your calendar to build this using the
native select menu element we set up the
button to open the select menu and give
it a slot to put in the newly selected
value
we insert the options which each have a
value but also contain a figure and a
paragraph and there we have it
remember how popovers support promotion
to the top layer well we need a way to
animate that and in order for all of
this to transition in and out smoothly
the web needs some way to animate
discrete properties these are properties
that typically weren't animatable in the
past such as animating to and from the
top layer and animating to and from
display none
as a part of the work to enable nice
transitions for popovers select menus
and even existing elements like
dialogues or custom components we're
enabling new Plumbing to support these
animations bringing them into the flow
of your animation or transition
timelines rather than swapping them at
zero seconds and creating a visual break
which brings us to interactions the last
stop on our Speed Run of web UI features
we already talked about anime and
discrete properties but there are also
some really exciting apis Landing in
Chrome around scroll driven animations
and view transitions
scroll driven animations enable you to
build CSS animations that rely on a
scroller rather than a timer this API
lets you build really smooth and
engaging interactions on a view timeline
so you can make Parallax effects entry
and exit effects and a lot of other neat
scroll-based experiences to manage user
attention and the best part is that this
API is declarative and you can do it all
in CSS without reaching for additional
scripting
and finally we have view transitions for
single page apps that landed in Chrome
111 this year with more capabilities for
multi-page support coming soon view
transitions allow you to smoothly
transition between paid States and
elements within a page what I love about
this demo by Maxi ferriera is that it
shows how these transitions can happen
while interactive elements like video
keep playing this is a massively
exciting feature that adds so much
smoothness to the web platform to really
elevate your web experiences and your
web apps
to learn more about view transitions
scroll driven animations and linear
easing function be sure to watch
brahmisfandam's talk on what's new in
web animations this talk goes into much
more detail about how to use these
features and where they really shine
[Music]
all of this adds up to a more robust and
solid web platform with less redundant
scripting more developer access to user
customization and more optimized
declarative web apis to keep up with all
of these changes and Landings in the web
space follow along on developer.com and
web.dev where our team is constantly
turning out news tips and tricks and
thank you for listening again be sure to
check out the what's new and web
animations talk and the how to create
personalized web experiences talk for
more web UI Landings and how to's I'll
see you online
[Music]
foreign